Speaker 1: All right, I want to start today with
the sort of like a funny little story that's
actually not really that funny. And it says a lot
about Senate Republicans, Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell. So yesterday on the show, I
kind of gave you guys my perspective on this. Joe
Biden has said he will choose a black woman to the
Supreme Court. And the question was posed to Mitch
McConnell in the context of, you know, sort of an
expectation that there may be funny business with
Mitch McConnell when it comes to Joe Biden's
eventual Supreme Court pick and so on and so
forth. And it doesn't even matter. Mitch McConnell
was asked how many black women work for him?
And first, Mitch McConnell twice appears
not to hear or understand the question
until the reporter pulls his mask down. And then
later, he says he doesn't actually know because
he doesn't have a quota for black women, which
was a very cynical attempt to turn the question
back as a racist question. And it completely
backfired. So let's look at the first clip here
is Mitch McConnell twice asked about how many
black women are on his staff and he can't hear
it. Doesn't understand it. How many black
Speaker 2: women do you have on staff
and how are they informing your decision to move
forward with this for this nomination? And same
question to the other senators. I'm anyone. How
many black women do you have on your staff and
are they informing your decision on how to
move forward with this for this nomination
and say question to the other senators? We are
Speaker 1: sorry. OK, so Mitch McConnell asks
that the reporters mask be pulled down.
That's Pablo Manrique as from Latino rebels.
So when when Pablo asked the question for
the third time, Mitch McConnell responds to
try to make the questions seem racist.
Speaker 2: How many black women do you
have on staff and how are they informing your
decision? Yeah, I know where this goes. Yeah,
actually, I haven't checked.
Speaker 3: We don't have a racial
quota and office, but I've had a
number of African-American employees,
both male and female, over the years and all kinds
of different positions, including speechwriter.
Speaker 1: So he doesn't know, and he wants to
make it seem like asking That is racist because
I have no quota. And if you're asking me how
many black women I have on staff, you know,
sort of like a binders full of women Mitt Romney
type incident, you're you're. That's a it's an
inappropriate question. It's a bizarre answer
because Senate Senate staffs are not so big
that you would have no idea. It's like,
are there? Do you have any black women
that that work for you? And we can argue
it doesn't matter. We can argue it's an
inappropriate question. I'm not saying those
things, but that's an argument we can have.
But is this at all believable? Like, it's
not. It's not racist to just know the answer.
You know, if someone came to me and said,
Sir, when you worked at Circuit City,
how many black women worked with you? This
was 20 years ago. There were about 80 people
that I worked with at Circuit City. I would
be able to tell you it was three or four.
That was a long time ago. And I'm saying three
or four because I don't remember whether all four
worked there with me at the same time or whatever
the case may be. But there were there were three
or four black women that worked with me at Circuit
City 20 years ago. If you and it's not just about
black women, if you said how many Asian men worked
with me as part of my internship, I remember when
I got licensed for life insurance and I sold life
insurance for a summer and I hated it and I knew
financial working in financial planning is not for
me. You say how many Asian men were part of the
intern cadre with you? I can tell
you with certainty. There were none.
There were none. There was no quota. It's not
racist to remember it. It just kind of like,
is what it is. And so when Mitch McConnell says
it's a total backfire. If if the question was how
many black women were at your last political rally
where there were 500 people saying, I don't know,
I didn't. It's it's completely reasonable and
plausible. If you said, you know, if you say,
David, how many Native Americans were with
you in fifth grade in your fifth grade class,
there were none. I know that there were no
Native Americans in my fifth grade class.
There were curricula about Native Americans. And
it was a topic that there were no Native Americans
in the class. It was a topic of discussion. It's
not racist to remember that. It's just very hard
when asked these questions, you know, and part
of the funny thing is the right. Loves to say.
And they are correct that as humans and many on
the left say this too, but the right also says
they say as humans, you can't not notice certain
attributes. When you meet someone without
prejudice, you're immediately judging. Am I
talking to an old person or a young person?
You're not going to have a conversation with
someone and then let it go. Was that a kid,
or was that an adult? I don't know. I don't see
age. It's like, No, of course you do. You would
know whether that was someone between 50 and
70 or a little kid. You would know that you're
immediately evaluating gender, and sometimes
you could be wrong, sure. But you're immediately
evaluating it. You're generally speaking
evaluating race. It doesn't mean you can always
tell is it was that person Indian-American or not.
It doesn't mean you're always doing it accurately,
but you're instantly making these evaluations
about people. So the right loves to say that.
And they're correct that these things happen. It
doesn't make you racist to notice those things.
But then Mitch McConnell is asked, like from your
Senate staff, how many black women do you have to
go to? I don't know. No, I mean, we don't have
any quotas and implies the question is racist.
The last part of this is if he really doesn't know
everybody who works for him. That's another level
of sort of like cringeworthy narcissism, which is
maybe a topic for another day. But like, if it's
true that he doesn't know, it's very, very strange
and it could be one of those like we don't ever
look at the senator sort of things. I actually
don't think that that's what it is. I think I
think the answer is zero. And Mitch McConnell was
just attempting to make the question seem racist.